coinbase ipo
here's what you need to know this is
story from forbes soon you'll be able to
buy the company
that helps you buy bitcoin coinbase the
largest cryptocurrency exchange in the
us has announced plans to go public
april 14th
with the ticker coin but it will uh it
will uh
uh pronounce that word for me uh adam it
will take the traditional ipo process of
hiring investment
banks to drum up interest and finance
deal instead coinbase plans to post its
share
straight on the nasdaq stock exchange
via so-called direct listing technique
pioneered big names
like spotify and palentino recent years
coinbase does not earn
money by charging you to store your
cryptocurrency in this popular wallet
service
instead it earns fees and commissions
when you actually buy and sell
cryptocurrency
a report from axios found that the
company was valued at 100 billion
dollars
when it sold shares on a private market
they're estimating it's going to be over
150 billion dollars which is more
than goldman sachs thoughts i
there has there ever been anything more
polarizing than bitcoin and the value of
it where you have some experts that are
so convinced
that this thing is gonna tank it's gonna
bottom out it's gonna you know continue
to fluctuate and then you have someone
like robert kiyosaki yesterday that's
right who said it's gonna go to what 1.5
million unbelievable i mean you've got
smart people on both ends of this
i think this is great for coinbase yeah
because you're going to get so many
naive people that want to feel like
they're in the game that they're
they're involved hey do you have any
bitcoin do you have any bitcoin well i
can't afford
one coin that cost sixty thousand
dollars but this can kind of say
at cocktail parties and with my peers
and in the locker room
when i'm getting dressed at the health
club yeah i've got bitcoin now or i'm
involved in cryptocurrency
i think there's going to be a lot of
people lose a lot of money in this thing
because they don't know what they're
doing
i'd say the vast majority of people that
get involved in something like this
don't know what they're doing but i
think it's a brilliant move by coinbase
what do you think yeah well there's a
couple different sides of the coin so to
speak so for the retail investors this
is essentially going to be sort of like
the robin hood
for crypto obviously robin hood there's
commission free trading and
you don't have to pay to make trades but
on this you do um
but yes i think a lot of people are
obviously super excited i think the ipo
is coming out
tomorrow i want to say but something
that people are not familiar with this
coin base that is also known as sort of
the bankers
bank where a lot of the big banks out
there the goldman sachs of the world the
um credit suisse deutsche bank
everything they're using
coinbase as well as sort of like um
a custodian for all their crypto this is
where they're holding all their crypto
so
the one thing that that everyone has to
be concerned about when it comes to
crypto and bitcoin
is legitimacy is it secure is there
fraud i mean you know we've been
experiencing some stuff here at
valuetainment with all the nonsense
that's going on that's the biggest
challenge at this point
yeah so so look there's a couple of
things i'll say that and i'll go into
what you just
brought up right now look number one is
the following the question like
a lot of people are asking is what is a
better investment coinbase or
bitcoin let me let me say that one more
time are you better off investing in
coinbase are you better off investing in
in crypt bitcoin so if you buy a bitcoin
today at what
62 000 record-breaking high pretty much
it's at 62k right
you buy coinbase today it's a 150
billion dollar company
is it more likely that coinbase will go
to 300 billion
or cr bitcoin will go to 160 125 billion
125 000. is it more likely
that crypto uh that uh uh coinbase
will go to a 1.5 trillion dollar
valuation
or is it more likely that uh uh
bitcoin is going to go to 620 000
valuation you know what i'm saying so i
mean a lot of people are like man i
totally missed on this whole coinbase
concept
but here's some news for people to be
thinking about if you missed it on
coinbase
there's another competitor out there
called binance
okay finance if you want to bring them
up binance b-i-n-a-n-c-e i think it came
out in 2017 if i'm not mistaken
again i may be wrong just type in
binance uh
no take out the stock just type the
phone right here e
binance okay right there 2017 came out
it was 2018 bonus was the largest crypto
turn right
just so you know they have a token in
binance
called binance coin that's got the
market
uh cap right now of 85 billion dollars i
think click on it to see if it shows
uh binance coin co-investors 89 billion
dollars as of right now you look at it
right there it's 89 billion
as of right now and they are competing
directly
with coinbase yeah so this this is not
going
away this isn't just a coin based
monopoly there's other guys that are
coming up and they're going to be
competing in the marketplace
we also have gemini we also have gemini
yes we do we also have gemini and but
here's what i want you to be thinking
about he just
he just made a comment you kai go to go
to valuetainment and go to
yesterday's um go to youtube channel
vitamin and go to yesterday's interview
with dan price dan price type in dan
price
yeah let's go to dan price's interview
so check this out click on his interview
press pause so we're not listening to
the audio yeah so now go to
press pause press pause
okay go to comments go lower so
look at anybody that responds so say
this was great i really love this debate
click on the replies
see that's the problem this guy creates
a channel
not creates a channel he creates an
account
that's same exact logo same exact name
and look what it says start investing in
crypto
btc and ethereum trade to make profits
and puts a number there the way they do
so
uh google doesn't catch it because that
says whatsapp number
people are responding to it we got an
email this morning got mario called the
guy this guy sends an email this morning
saying hey
i gave you guys fifteen thousand dollars
of bitcoin you know
i need to get my money back that is
patrick owes me sixteen thousand dollars
right because
this guy named brian todd who works for
you guys
said that you guys if you i'm going to
get this mentorship and mario calls him
this morning that comes like this is not
us buddy
so the part with bitcoin where i believe
guys like him could potentially get the
government to step in
is those types of transactions that
happen
it's affecting people have spent nearly
a half a million dollars with
others who are saying this is not
because the same thing they're doing
here go to another comment by the way
look at this it's not a real channel go
to about how are they even able to
you can you can pull up how can they get
the name valuetainment but it's not
called valuetainment
it's just a logo so look when it started
february 25th so go back to the other to
our channel and go to another comment
that says something good
so it's going to go lower go a little
lower go a little lower go look the one
that doesn't have too many replies like
he tried to question patrick okay click
on that right there view okay again boom
again
by the way there are if i tell you one
thousand it's a small number
he has responded to fifty 000 comments
this fake account we keep reporting it
to youtube
and youtube has not taken it down so if
i go on there
and i click on the channel to uh hide it
okay click on the channel right there
that is putting the comments
click on it right there to see to no no
the guy that commented
click on him the guy that the guy
valuetainment the fake account
okay so if we go out here to try to
block him
okay we report him and that's all you
can do
this is a separate one this just got
started april 9th so it's like
50 different fake accounts that they're
creating and people are falling for
scary so here's 12 000 of bitcoin i want
to get you know into
the cryptocurrency patrick strategy i
would never have a cryptocurrency
strategy because for people to follow my
content they know we're not a crypto
but the challenge with crypto you get a
thousand of these that go to regulators
you get ten thousand of these you get a
hundred thousand of these who typically
ruins a great opportunity
who scumbags scumbags con men right
who typically ruins a great opportunity
and brings over regulation yeah
people who abuse a great platform so
well any time that there's major money
obviously you're gonna have people
trying to do products you're gonna have
what's gonna happen i'm hoping this does
this is
why crypto is eventually going to get
regulated i mean that's kind of me i
mean you can't have stuff like this
there's nothing i can do about it and
pat if this is happening in
valuetainment imagine how many other
channels this is happening to imagine
how many are the people
yeah they're going to people with
credibility and they're responding to
them and they're doing this on linkedin
left and right i have like 50 fake
accounts on linkedin they all block me
so i can't block them i don't know if
this makes sense or not so they start
the account
so it's a strategy they use they create
a linkedin account
they block the person they're copying so
you can't see it
they're responding to all the different
comments that people are posting
and then you're getting money out of
them saying hey if you'd like to be part
of a private
group hey send us a bitcoin here and
they're not taking it off credit cards
they're not taking it off any kind of
real
so any of this again that that part of
abuse could bring a lot of attention
from the regulator
yeah who's at fault here meaning
clearly the scumbags the fraudsters
they're guilty here they're at fault but
is there some naivete from people just
handing over their
crypto to somebody they meet online are
you not having are you not talking to
anybody on the phone
is there no vetting process are you just
trusting what you're seeing online but
you know what
what's the deal with that's your loyal
fan base if they see that logo they're
getting an issue yeah but that might be
legit
i mean come on i i mean look you have
three million followers on instagram
hundreds and hundreds of followers on
facebook
on valuetainment there's three we have
three million subscribers suppose we
have multiple channels
i mean little old me with you know
however many thousand followers i have
i get fake accounts and i get free and i
decided i have to tell people and it
happens all the time
and i have 25 000 followers so how many
people are
you have credibility though okay well so
do you so to you is my point
so my point is how do people not
understand
all right like well there's some product
this is this is the part where the
concept of getting verified
is very important the concept of seeing
who's sending your message
of a verified account is very important
but still
the naive part of getting ripped off
that's gonna happen man you gotta you
listen there's not a single person you
cannot tell me you've never been ripped
off before you cannot tell me you know
everyone has everyone has and you're
gonna fall for it at one point
that's a little bit without having a
conversation a little bit you guys are
forgetting one
element here of blame and that's the
social media companies i mean that they
can't have some sort of filter or you
send them
this fake account that's so obvious
because they're being bombarded billions
of times so for them to track
all of them youtube's sitting there
saying how can we track a billion yeah
that's exactly they took one down and
three pop up and we can't so what's the
game uh they used to play
whack-a-mole isn't it amazing how
quickly they can take down the stuff
they want to any sort of negative talk
or political talk that they don't want
up there that disappears pretty quickly
yeah so anyways listen the whole point
is very happy
for the coinbase folks yes crypto
community
i have to tell you you can go change
your profile in the description for
those of you guys that were in crypto
pre-bitcoin being a thousand dollars
some of you guys that weren't there
before was 500
you can put in your description today i
told you so you can literally put in
your description quote
i told you so me on crypto if you were
there pre 1000 you should in your
twitter profile
put something like that because you were
right and a lot of people sat there and
said
i don't know and by the way i was a part
of it i was one of them that sat there
and said i don't know what's going to
happen with crypto we don't know what
direction it's going to go to
my biggest concern from day one till
today with crypto has been what what's
been my biggest concern from day one
till today
regulation that's been my number one
biggest concern
and it's not changing just so you know
that so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye